hey guys i'm philip molina and this is a
breakdown of the Walking Dead Season six
Episode twelve but not tomorrow yet this
is probably one of the darkest episodes
we've ever seen a lot of very good
people or formerly good people turn into
just cold-blooded murderers and some
little Carol wasn't one of them even
though she's feeling like one this
episode there's a lot to talk about so
let's just dive right into the opening
images so this happy banjo song that's
opening the episode is called weeds or
wild flowers and the lyrics are kind of
about gardening but more specifically
how you can work and work at planning
the perfect garden but ultimately
nature's gonna take its course and no
matter how hard you try can't change
what you've done you might get a garden
that's just full of weeds and that's
exactly how Carol is feeling right now
she's working so hard to keep up this
perfect pretty Suzie homemaker
appearance but the world keeps reminding
her that deep down she's just a
pragmatic killer also note the blood
sprayed shirt moments after the song
clearly says Carol baking and passing
out for a beatin acorn cookies to hide
her inner killer it's all pretty
reminiscent to that show Dexter and it's
the opening sequence where it's a
different sociopathic killer who's
pretending to live his life like normal
day or he's making just a simple
breakfast but he also even passes out
his own sweet treats for him it's
doughnuts for Carol it's cookies but
they're both just trying to hide in
plain sight
basically the point is if anybody ever
gives you a dessert they're probably a
murderer also you got to remember
cookies are a connection to Carol's
relationship to the little cookie
monster Sam for us to pieces last season
she told him that baking cookies helps
her forget why she's sad unfortunately
now cookies kind of remind her of her
guilt over scaring Sam kind of literally
two dead so that's why she leaves one on
his grave and real quick only because
this show is about zombies did I kind of
think for a moment it might be fun to
see Sam's zombie ham like shoot up
through the grave and grab the cookie oh
yeah they chose not to do that
opportunity missed
also did you catch a moment of
transition where everything feels all
happy-go-lucky and everybody smiling and
then one Rick and company show up they
have this terrible disruption is about
to come to all this cheeriness and right
as that is starting to settle in we
suddenly hear thunder and we get this
shot of a storm that's rolling in so
just applying the danger that lies ahead
so after this speech where rick is
trying to convince the town to attack
the saviors and also where of course
everybody else is cast in shadow but you
can just leave it to Jesus to be the
only person cast in a ray of light
symbolizing humanity's best hope or
pepper but anyway after all that we get
that interesting realization that carol
has been keeping track of all the people
she's killed according to Carol that's
Ryan who was Lizzy and Micah's father
Karen and David who are the sick people
that she burned in the prison Lucy
herself was that crazy or little girl
who gave us that phrase look at the
flowers Lizzy the three people that she
may have shot at terminus Mary who was
also a terminus of a candle woman and
maybe a few other people there in that
handle room and then seven of the wolves
when they attack so altogether that's 18
and the blood on her hand is definitely
starting to weigh on her but also if
you're like me you're wondering is her
math right that's considering we are in
the zombie apocalypse and it's maybe a
little hard to keep track of all the
murders you've committed but else it
gets a little complicated that she
counts Ryan when she actually killed him
because he was about to turn into a
walker and that makes a little weird
that she doesn't count doing the same
thing to her own husband Edie
I don't know if you remember but she
takes him out with a freakin pickaxe and
it's so gross but then also at terminus
she Snipes like two guys and then maybe
she kills the third person the girl who
gets eaten alive when she blasts up in
the fences maybe that's why it's like a
question mark it gets a question mark is
appropriate there but also the candle
woman area I don't know she doesn't seem
to kill anyone else other than Mary in
that moment but she has a four down
there people giving a good guess is that
the candle woman was like nine months
pregnant with triplets so Carol's ago
let's make that four either way doesn't
exactly matter because it kind of gets
balanced out a moment later we see she
put down seven for the Wolves but I
think Carol killed way more than that at
the
okay definitely like eight or nine and
then she puts an end to Aaron's misery
she takes out the alcohol so that kind
of puts Carol's number closer to twenty
than eighteen but I actually think it's
totally fine that her numbers aren't
perfect the fact that she realized that
she needs to start writing these down
because she's kind of losing track of
how many people it's been that's the
whole point of this scene she's worried
she might be losing her humanity here
and the moment that you don't know how
many people you've killed that's
probably the moment that it doesn't
matter anymore you're too far gone at
that point and this will come back a
little bit later with Glenn and he now
before we move on I do want to point out
that by the end of this episode Rick
will have tied the governor for 33 on
screen human kills that's crazy but also
kind of put things into perspective
about just how far rick has come and who
he's now become also daryl you blew up
eight saviours at the end of this
episode he's got 19 kills this shows
clearly pointing out that's justified or
not this group is just as much full of
killers as any of the other groups that
we've encountered
okay now I'm moving on you get some
rounds of couple drama it's not too much
to say about Glenn and Maggie here so
we'll just skip to Carol freaking making
out with Tobin since when is that a
thing
also Tobin totally calls her out that
this is not the real Carol he's dealing
with you can do things just terrify me
here cookies and her kisses he knows
tomorrow she'll be back to being this
ruthless killer kind of like how
tomorrow the garden will be back to
being full of weeds and Carol is so
desperate to cling to this fake but
really comfortable image she set up for
herself if she named drops the episodes
title they're saying that's all over
this episode a lot of people wish that
they could stay and today that they're
in where they're making do and things
are just calm for once but too bad
that's not how day's work also wasn't
there somebody else that carol was
supposed to be having some sort of
romance with who was that again alright
hello darkness my old friend sorry buddy
oh and somebody who definitely wishes
that things would not change yet and she
could stay and today is Rosita who gets
so terribly dumped by Abraham here he
tells her it was only with her because
he thought she was the last woman on
earth holy crap that is so mean it also
hits a nerve with me because I may or
may not have been told in 10th grade by
Shannon Elle that whether or not I was
the last man on earth she still wouldn't
do it and that's a true story but
whatever who cares also what a creepy ug
move to just stare and watch that whole
thing that's actually a callback to one
of the first times we see Abraham and
Roseate his relationship starting to
develop and ads are having sex for data
calls out that Eugene is watching them
bone Abraham's like don't worry about
happy talking plus so I guess it's
fitting that Eugene also is there to
witness the end of their relationship
he is really rubbing it in though with
that Virginia is for lovers shirt and
not goal dude moving on
roots plan to use the fake severed head
of Gregory to get inside the Savior's
compound is definitely a reference to
the famous Trojan horse idea from Greek
mythology that's the story of Odysseus
and his soldiers using a fake gift in
their face of the hollow wooden horse to
get inside the wall to Troy and then
when the Trojans accept that gift in
them and let them through Odysseus
sneaks out from his hiding place in the
horse in his case opens the gates to his
men and then they murder all the Trojans
in their sleep just like we're about to
see brick and his people do it's a very
clever idea but it's also looks so
terrible and so violent and we will get
back to all of that in just a second
also when they're scouting for Gregory
look-alikes
one of the walkers that they encounter
looks like he's gotten in a fight with
somebody else who has sword skills I
look at all that chopping and slicing it
definitely seems like sword works well
but anyway once they've got their heads
picked there's this really great missile
moment here with the three heads the
middle head was modeled on the face of
Walking Dead producer Greg Nicotero
that's the guy that's behind this shows
gory visual effects I'm Nessen when they
go with but the head on the right which
doesn't look enough like Gregory for
them to use it's probably because it was
model
on Johnny Depp that's awesome I love
when shows do that but it's also funny
how many shows have celebrity heads
laying around Game of Thrones shuffle
seasons back had george w bush's head
just on a spike in his shot hilarious
and before we move on to the attack i
want to call out that after rick states
his plan he gives the shortest pep talk
we've ever heard from a man who
definitely likes to give speeches the
only motivation you can muster at this
moment in this simple phrase this is how
we that's it it's that simple and it's
another one of these moments that's 'ok
waiting the people of the show to the
walkers since the walkers technically
don't mean any harm either they just
have a hunger and yeah it happens to
mean that people will die but that's not
part of the moral equation for them like
our crew here this is how they eat that
simple oh and it's also a bit of a
callback to gareth from terminus
explaining why they're cannibals
commands gotta eat along with his kill
count that's just like one more thing
that showing greek has become about as
vicious as all of the shows past
villains
okay so night falls and the plan is in
motion and we encounter the Savior's
compound and the design of this place is
all full of imagery and references that
the creators are sneaking in first off
this area is surrounded by satellites
and the main building is even topped by
one so we know they're important because
months ago the show makers showed us a
sneak peak of this satellite on their
instagram but why are they important
well one satellites represent
communication with distant groups of
people and this whole savior storyline
is all about our group being put in
contact with all sorts of new
communities but to the fact that this
station that supposedly belongs to
Meegan's people well the way we're left
at the end of the episode not having
actually met Megan and there's clearly
other saviors that Rick and his company
haven't met yet it all makes me think
that this isn't negan's actual compound
but instead it's just an outpost or
here's some wordplay for you
a satellite location of negan's also i
remember on the last episode i pointed
out that these outsiders are kind of
being set up in a way where because they
belong to a world outside of rick's
world and to his people they're almost
like signs of intelligent
life kind of like aliens and their being
represented by the star balloons and
stuff I'm gonna skip over the fact that
this location is so weird-looking it
kind of looks like a spaceship with its
weird lights and stuff but I'll jump to
the fact that in real life at least
rumor has it that this building was
built specifically to look for alien
light so I don't think that like
Meegan's people are aliens or anything
but I do think that the show's creators
are trying to pare that up a little bit
that to Rick and his people that's how
weird it is to encounter a whole other
community they might as well be aliens
but enough about buildings uh-huh let's
go inside one of them for one of the
craziest most insane kills we've ever
seen on the show and Rick might not be
alone in doing it but he is the first to
do it this silent stabbing of a savior
in his sleep wow that is one of the
darkest turns the show has ever made let
alone brick scared driving the show as a
whole and despite what the characters
are arguing there's not the most solid
argument of self-defense here this is
murder
technically I'm just thankful we did see
the knife actually go into the guy's
head but I feel like they're all
stabbing them through the eye hole
because it's like a vertical angle
straight down and it's hard to get
through foreheads or skull and I don't
like imagining this actually so let's
keep going these two saviors are Glenn's
first human kills this show does like
earn this moment for Glenn but he and
Heath earlier we're talking about how
murder changes you and now we actually
see how devastated Glenn looks and it's
really interesting when Glenn makes that
second kill instead of having Keith do
it because it kind of equates it all to
losing your virginity like once you do
it once it kind of doesn't matter if you
do it a second time it was the first
time they counted he's even making the
same face you make when you lose your
virginity or I think that's the face you
make I wouldn't know right Shannon
no I'm kidding what's wrong luckily just
as we are almost about to judge Glenn
for being as ruthless as Rick normally
is this show makes sure to remind us
that these people the Savior's they kind
of deserve this like they literally
sleep under these gruesome Polaroids of
people whose heads they bashed in now
this is technically foreshadowing
something that's gonna probably happen
and it's terrifying and I'm totally
dreading it let's
say imagine how tragic that would be if
you cared about somebody in those
pictures let's move on just before we
get to the really intent shootout we
stop for a quick confessional moment
with Tara and father Gabriel I guess
she's feeling really guilty and she
confesses her sins and a little known
fact about confessions it's not actually
the priest that is forgiving you of your
sins it's God that you're supposedly
seeking forgiveness from so it seems
very purposeful that while Tara was
confessing to Gabriel it's Jesus who was
listening all along and actually the one
that settles the matter for her it's
also probably worth pointing out that
I'm actually not an overly religious
person but this show definitely deals
with religious themes a lot that's the
only reason it comes up so much anyway
the shootout it was very well
choreographed and it was so heart
pounding I Aaron gets his first kill in
it Rosita freaking splatters brains out
of the camera but also it's really
interesting that moments after Glenn has
spared Heath from having to pop his
murder
cherry he actually gets spared again
because they have him shoot through the
door and that's kind of a lot like how a
firing squad works and real-life firing
squads
they purposely put a blank round inside
of one of the rifles so that no one
knows for sure if they're actually the
one who killed the inmate it honestly
just helps these people live with
themselves so it kind of lets he keep
his murder beat cards if time like how
people are like oh it didn't count
because we did in the but but I wouldn't
know so let's move on a definite
miserable moment here with Abraham and
I'm not referring to the hilarious fact
that they knew that is bright bushy
ginger hair with hopefully be seen from
like a mile away so they made him wear a
black bandanna not talking about that
I'm talking about when he's busting down
doors and there's obviously a room where
they just grow marijuana what's
interesting about that is that they
could just do that
out in the open but instead they hide it
away inside of this room almost as much
as they hide away their weapons I think
that's because they know that if they
keep their drugs under
Kikki they can force people to buy them
or trade for them and that seems to be
how this weird but kind of functional
society works they seem to really value
the idea of bartering and trade and in
Alexandria that's different they're all
about people just get their rations
I got like communism or something so
it's just an interesting way to see
economic ideologies that are working in
different ways in the zombie apocalypse
it's also no surprise why the saviors
need to steal everybody else's food cuz
negan's got the munchies then moving on
a Gabriel's big moment they're doing a
pretty good job by the way of making him
kind of likable now he's just continuing
this badass tree and he quotes the Bible
right before he shoots a guy but not
your heart be troubled in my father's
house are many mansions if it were not
so I would have told you I go prepare a
place for you which makes them almost as
cool as what they're referencing here
and I will strike down upon thee with
great vengeance and furious anger and
you will know my name is the Lord when I
lay my vengeance upon thee it's
interesting how the show can turn kind
of annoying characters into almost fan
favorites just by having them make the
correct logical decisions that they
should make like a normal human being
though the next time you kill someone I
think you should try this line Maya good
deals as we head into the closing images
we get this closing song it's hoes ears
arsonist lullaby which you might
remember as the kind of moody song from
the hole Season 6 trailer the song is
about a person who in this case it's an
arsonist someone who sets fires who's
driven by their inner fire to do bad
things like the person knows that
technically he has a choice and we hear
that line from the song as we see Morgan
who's constantly telling everybody you
have a choice you don't have to give in
to being close you soon
you have futures and as the singer talks
about staring into the open flame we see
Morgan doing the same thing into open
flame but the singer points out what
Morgan's thinking in that buyer there's
a lot of power there and it might not be
possible to turn away from that fire
Morgan might not be able to convince
people that there is another way but the
fact that Morgan is trying to reach
handle that fire into making prison bars
is a callback to how Eastman used a
prison cell to show Morgan the
alternative to killing the other way but
Morgan doesn't know if it's gonna work
and even the singer doesn't really seem
to agree with him the song goes on to
say
always keep
and I think that's explaining how Rick
and company have done what was necessary
to survive but just like how carol was
keeping counter for kills I think the
least part is just as important you
can't ever let go full force the demons
can't take over it's a fine line and
when you do let go of that leash and you
do give into the demons that's when you
become the villain this episode is full
of people who are terrified of what's
ahead for them and what will happen when
their actions catch up to them will
their demons take over will their garden
turn to weeds they wonder if they're bad
people and they want more than anything
to just keep things the same and not
have to face these truths that are
waiting for them tomorrow but right at
the end here the night is finished it's
the next morning they can't say it's not
tomorrow yet it is tomorrow and that
means they have to face the consequences
of who they are and what they've done
and that's the moment this show reveals
the Rickon company that Maggie and Carol
been taken that's something you want to
chat about that's when it all goes to
share cuz you might not think it in the
apocalypse but unfortunately tomorrow
always comes okay so just one real
question this week do you think these
characters are justified in what they've
done like sneaking around murdering
people in their sleep that's definitely
a new level of terrible and I get why
they did it but can you really call them
the heroes of the show still like are
they the good guys what do you think let
me know in the comments also if you
liked this video hit like on it and
share it with your friends and subscribe
if you want to see more of them and
follow any rockstars on Twitter if you
want to know when videos come out and
follow me on Twitter at fimo if you want
to talk to me at all also I stopped and
figured out my new setup that I will
I'll see you next time thanks a lot bye